it's nice to see you again great good to
see you eight crazy nights yes animated
film yeah yeah hanukkah movie
yeah this was important for you to make
you always you want this was important
for you to make a hanukkah movie why
goes back to third grade
i was in class art class conan yeah and
mine in my business making my holiday
project i was working on my hanukkah
project the other
kids were working on a christmas project
that's that's excellent
uh the teacher leaves the room
uh four um kids who don't
celebrate hanukkah start kind of
shoving me they started shoving you yeah
i was a kid you know they're pushing me
throwing me to the ground you're
different than us that kind of thing
i was shook up uh yeah but i
stayed strong didn't cry you didn't cry
i didn't want to cry didn't want to give
him that satisfaction i just kind of
stared at him
i was like one day i i'm gonna move to
hollywood
and i am going to make a hanukkah movie
all the world's going to love it and
i'm going to have enough money at that
time to pay a doctor to take this paper
mache menorah out of my
ass
it's terrible but it's gone now
got rid of it most of most of it is out
yeah your childhood stories are so
heartwarming yeah that's what i love
about them
now there aren't a lot of hanukkah films
there's like i think
a million movies about christmas but not
a lot of hanukkah movies why well
i think there's two reasons for that and
uh uh well first of all uh there's not
that many jewish people
right there's there's more people so
fewer jewish people right exactly fewer
jewish people that's number one number
two i think it's the the greeting
merry christmas to me is sounds better
than happy hanukkah
uh just just fun to say merry christmas
hey merry christmas how you doing merry
christmas what's up merry christmas
uh happy hanukkah is nice but there's
happy birthday and there's happy
thanksgiving happy new year
kind of steps on it a little bit right
it's not special
it's not special anymore so i thought of
it new greeting uh this year for
uh hanukkah the jewish people out there
if you want to
take it from me and i think we could
spread this mate
next time you see someone during the
hanukkah season just look at them and go
hanukkah skadoo
[Applause]
yeah that's nice that really flows too
i don't know if it's good or bad i
didn't put a lot of fun
yeah you just sang hanukkah three third
installment of the hanukkah song on star
night live
yeah that was a good time to be back
there yeah it's nice to go back and
visit the old home
yes you and i used to yeah shareholders
was pretty crazy when we were together
back then
it actually wasn't crazy at all
but do do a lot of do a lot of people
come up to you and say because the song
is all about you mentioning
uh different jewish celebrities so
people come up to you and say like come
on work me into the song because it's
just a famous song now yeah i do i have
a lot of
a lot of just just people on the street
hey you got to put me in that song man
dude throw me in that man i got people
who aren't you are say hey throw me in
that song yeah
i think they're just doing that because
they think it'll help them get into law
school
but it might too
what's i don't know a lot i grew up in a
catholic house and i never kind of
understood
like christmas it's really easy right
you know you you come down and there's a
bunch of presents under the tree on the
25th and that's it
whereas hanukkah there's like it's
complicated there's different days and
different presents and all that kind of
stuff
what's the weirdest hanukkah gift that
you got what's the strangest of the
gifts that you got
this was a my mother kind of went nuts
one year with uh trying to
surprise me eight days long so first
night she
i open up a little present it's uh uh
two double eight batteries
and i'm like hey all right and i'm like
mom where is this going she's like
you'll see
yeah and day two a couple of more
batteries you know
seven days of it the batteries and i
know it's leading up to the big one so
day eight open it up like a nine
inch vibrator
and i'm like oh my very funny you know
but you know that vibrator only takes
ten batteries what about the
four extra ones she goes i thought you
could put those in your hiney too booby
yeah so i could i couldn't believe it
you know
what a wonderful well i was i was seven
years old
you were seven what a wonderful mom
oh yeah she was she liked to have fun
with the highlight she put a lot of
thought into that one yeah yeah
all right you know i want to mention one
thing your your movie punch drunk love
yeah came out recently yes you went to
the i went to the privilege i went to
the festival
right here in lincoln center yes and
true story i'm sitting there with my
wife for
the movies going people really love the
movie and exactly halfway through the
movie and i'm not making this up
halfway through the movie suddenly in
front of our row and like to the left
an older woman started going
[Music]
and all of a sudden like there was a lot
of commotion the film stopped the lights
came up and people rushed in to see if
this older woman was okay
yeah and the woman seemed fine but she
started getting mad
that people were like because it's you
know people were looking at her right
right
so uh she got something she started
going like don't look at me
don't look at me and i couldn't really
see the woman but i was convinced that
it was you
doing it does it seem like such an adam
thing to do right i was convinced and i
don't know if it was you or not but
don't look at me stop looking at me
and then they you know there was a
commotion and they started the film
again but yeah no she's better now i
heard
i heard yeah i swear that was you that
wasn't i was eating chinese food
okay all right good yeah but i did hear
about that yeah that's a good alibi for
anything not me
i was eating chinese food no look at me
all right we'll take a break we'll have
more with adam stanley in just a second
stick around
you